To get x by itself, we need to subtract b over 2a from both sides. Then, both of
our fractions on the right-hand side have a denominator of 2a, so it's really
easy to combine them. This gives us, finally, a final answer of x equals
negative b, plus or minus the square root of b squared minus 4ac all over 2a.
You can heave a giant sigh of relief now, that was a lot of work and it involved
some complicated Algebra. I think that in doing this, you had to use almost all
of the skills you've learned in this course so far. So, this is super
impressive, I am so proud of you. So, what does this mean again? Remember, we
started out with an equation in this form, a quadratic equation, ax squared plus
bx plus c equals 0. Working from that, we've solved for x which means that now,
we have a formula where if we know the coefficients of a quadratic equation
written in this form, we can find the values of x that satisfy it. In other
words, for any parabola we have, if we can write its equation in standard form,
ax squared plus bx plus c equals y, then we can set y equal to 0 and find the
x-intercepts. This is huge, this is incredibly powerful. And we did all of these
by just completing the square. And, of course, doing some other algebraic
manipulations.